the upcoming Disney Plus series the
mandalorian takes place during an
unexplored time period in the Star Wars
universe it's set five years after
Return of the Jedi and will serve as a
bridge between that film and the force
awakens
since the time gap that separates those
two films is 30 years there are bound to
be plenty of revelations mixed into the
Mandalorian and apparently fans won't
have to wait long to experience at least
one of them according to the New York
Times the Mandalorians very first
episode contains a major spoiler the
times didn't reveal what the spoiler is
but it did say this and a throwaway line
tucked and a lengthy article about the
impending November 12th launch of Disney
Plus the Mandalorian which contains a
dramatic Star Wars universe spoiler in
the first episode and will be available
the moment Disney Plus starts has been
as heavily promoted as a traditional
future film with billboards 30-second
television commercials radio spots and
digital ads this shows time frame offers
up some tantalizing possibilities about
the bombshell spoiler that awaits by
taking place between the fall of the
Empire and the rise of the first-order
the Mandalorian is primed to show how
the first order came to be as show
creator jon favreau told Entertainment
Weekly what could happen in the 30 years
between celebrating the defeat of the
Empire and then the first order you come
in on episode 7 the first order are not
just starting out so somehow things
weren't necessarily managed as well as
they could have been if the galaxy ended
up in hot water again like that contrary
to the rumors that swirled when a series
was first announced according to the
show's creators the Mandalorian is not
about boba fett main actor Pedro Pascal
plays an as-yet unnamed Mandalorian
bounty hunter who operates in the seedy
outer rim of the galaxy Carl Weathers
portrays grief carga the head of a
bounty hunting guild and an occasional
ally of the Mandalorian while Giancarlo
Esposito plays a former Imperial
governor named moth Gideon Verner
Hertzog's character is a crime boss
Tycho ytt voices droid IG 11 and gina
carano plays x rebel shock trooper and
current mercenary cara doon they two
will cross paths with the Mandalorian in
their own unique ways perhaps the most
obvious spoiler is that the series crew
has been bamboozling us all
and the show really is about Boba Fett
or someone related to hims the gloved
Mandalorian armor gauntlet of Boba Fett
grabs onto the sand outside the Sarlacc
pit but it's hard to see the universe
wide implications of that despite some
fans desire to see it we realize that he
survived his fault
during the battle at Jabba's palace ship
maybe the first episode of the
Mandalorian could offer a spoiler that
helps set up the rise of Skywalker the
series premieres on November 12 and Star
Wars Episode nine opens in theaters
December 20th that gives fans plenty of
time to catch the Mandalorian before
watching the film so if the series se
reveals how Emperor Palpatine survived
the destruction of the second Death Star
fans would be extremely motivated to
pony up for a full Disney Plus
subscription to watch the show before
seeing the movie Disney has already
hinted at seating its upcoming MCU
offerings on Disney Plus with story
beats that will affect later films
namely the streaming series one division
is set to tie into the film Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness hey
wait a minute if he holds the reality
gem that means he can jump from
different realities this will be our
link from to the Marvel Universe from
the Star Wars universe and probably not
the other big possibility is renewed
cannon from the old expanded universe
some fans think Mara Jade Luke
Skywalker's wife and the EU may be in
the Mandalorian and fabro didn't exactly
deny it when asked about it he told E W
in September 2019 I don't want to talk
about anything that might be fun for
people to discover part of what's fun to
see if we could merge the worlds of the
original trilogy the prequels the
sequels the Clone Wars and what's been
considered canon up to this point and
what's been considered part of Legends I
think this show offers an opportunity to
bring in all those elements the only way
to know for certain what this big star
where spoiler truly is would be to tune
into the debut episode of demanda War II
on hitting Disney Plus on November 12th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you